you know the way that you
describe rob and big came out of this
whole thing
i think there's a pretty important piece
missing there which is
the first dc video it came out in 2003
and you had this absolutely [ __ ]
genius
like sort of a gimmick for your part
where you said dude
[ __ ] skateboarding [ __ ] security
getting getting nailed by foot trying to
deal with security
i'm so sick of dealing with security i
got
security to deal with security and that
was
that was how big came into the picture
and it was such a [ __ ] genius thing
it was such an
excellent part that whole dc video was
so magnificent
and of course that served as the proof
of concept
for what would be the robin big show
right like that i mean yeah did you
basically just show them that as
a in your pitch like here's what it is
with robin big you know
like there was so much pressure on me on
the dc video
everybody was so gnarly and i just knew
that like [ __ ] man i just i'm never
gonna be able to film a part
to sit next to all these guys like
they're all filming the [ __ ]
gnarliest parts like
you know i i like to say i've made the
most money
per trick landed in the history of
skateboarding
and how many bail photos i've had and
how the limited amount of [ __ ]
footage i've actually generated
but like i conceptually
as i was like trying to think like oh my
god it would be funny to come up with a
skit
and then when it was like just the idea
of i'ma bring a security guard
to deal with security guards just just
connected so
quickly and then even when we we we just
went to like a security agency in san
diego we're like we're just looking for
like
a really lovable like big cool they're
like oh we got the perfect guy
wow that's how you met meg yeah it was
like literally
didn't weren't friends at all was like a
straight like casted from a
security agency and the day we met to
shoot it
it was just like instant like oh we you
know we just
instantly were in it and like already
like
improving and doing the most ridiculous
stuff
um that set the stage but it was really
like look me and him would
man i broke my arm one year and
in that era before before tv and all
that [ __ ] i mean
because he rolled with big zeus and big
bam bam
right so he had like this trio of mega
men
and then we would roll together so we
would roll to vegas and all put on suits
and [ __ ] they would be like it would
just be us three and everybody was like
convinced i was like some sort of like
super wealthy billionaire you know like
you know when we were pitching the show
i was telling them a story of how
we went to vegas and there was a roy
jones junior fight and i was like [ __ ]
it like just
let's just try to get in so i walked up
with all three of them i said excuse me
ma'am i don't have the ticket but i'm
going to pass if you don't mind it's
like oh go right ahead
right so i [ __ ] it's like just
straight on that power perception like
we all [ __ ] roll down this shit's
working
and i [ __ ] walk all the way down to
like four seats from the [ __ ] ring i
said man if you don't mind
we're going to sit right here she said
oh go go right ahead and we just [ __ ]
watched the roy jones junior fight all
four of us
and chicks kept coming up to me like hey
can i give him my number
and it's like just just because
it was like one little dude surrounded
by these three giant guys
that's that i think how we sort of
positioned
and tried to to drive the show as
like hey the um
the odd couple you know even when i took
the show to pitch it in it was like i
took in the song people let me tell you
about my
best friend but they wouldn't buy that
show
right it was when mtv was stealing like
we need scripts and you know and even
jeff wasn't really connected to being
able to ultimately write scripts in that
type of production
and they ended up buying the show rob
durdeck's rules to success
and rule number one was always surround
yourself with good people
that was the pilot and this was
uh big black was like the person you
surround yourself with right it was so
whack
and we shot the pilot it was [ __ ] except
for when i go off script and we were we
were going the script and then we
we started freestyling a little bit
about where he said he could outrun me
if we were in prison he could catch me
i'm like you ain't [ __ ] catching me
in prison first of all and then it
turned into you couldn't even [ __ ]
like you couldn't beat me in a foot race
and then it's like let's [ __ ] go
right then it turned that freestyle
moment became sort of the anchor of like
okay we'll let these guys
get off like stop forcing them to be in
a script and let them go
and then shane uh nickerson
came over because he was a story editor
from the
the jessica simpson show and then he
pieced it together and was like you need
to just let these guys
be themselves and then it circled all
the way back to rob and big
for the pilot you know so you didn't so
you didn't have to make a pilot
for the rob durdix rules of success
you know we shot it and then midway
through and all the pickups they
reshaped it
into robin big right and it was
originally robin big black and the
network
wouldn't let it be big black and it was
like a black woman that was running the
network at the time
and like you know we had to call her and
she was like absolutely not
and and in the beginning like when we
would hear rob and big
you know it you know would be like if if
jackass would call
what's
i guess i guess right you know like the
because we only knew it like he was big
black he wasn't big
right so it was like super strange for
us in the beginning where it was like
rather big sounds so weird
yeah dude